ja also meine große Sorge ist dass es
eben nicht reicht jetzt noch eine kleine
große Gas und strompreisbremse zu machen
sondern die Unternehmen in Deutschland
sind massiv verunsichert Investoren
machen inzwischen einen Bogen um
Deutschland wir haben einen stillen
Schwund sondern ich das von Firmen die
nicht insolvent gehen sondern Firmen die
einfach zum Jahresende oder zu Ostern zu
machen die inzwischen alles abmelden wir
werden die Statistiken dann spätestens
Ostern auswerten können von der
Industrie und Handelskammer von der
Handwerkskammer auch von den
Gewerbeämtern in den Städten und
Kommunen und werden sehen das ganz viele
Firmen zugemacht haben im Osten
vielleicht mehr
prozentual gesehen weil bei uns nach der
Wende die meisten Leute gegründet haben
da waren die zwischen 30 und 45 sind
alle im Rentenalter oder kurz davor
wollen die Firma übergeben und keiner
traut sich bei diesen unsicheren
Bedingungen eine Firma zu kaufen oder
neu aufzumachen das Problem ist ja nicht
dass wir dann bis Ostern vielleicht ohne
Blackout durchkommen sondern das Problem
ist das auf Jahre hinaus nicht klar ist
wie die Wirtschaft in diesem Land
kalkulieren muss mit welchen
Rahmenbedingungen sie fertig werden muss
wie die Preise sich entwickeln weil
nämlich die Regierung nicht in der Lage
ist eine 4 oder 5 Jahre Sicherheit
wenigstens mal zu projizieren das ist
alles nur auf Sicht fahren kein
Unternehmer der ernsthaft in der
Industrie beschäftigt oder Beschäftigte
hat und Firma hat kann sich das leisten
mehrere Jahre auf sich zu fahren das
geht einfach nicht und deswegen haben
wir wahrscheinlich Insolvenzen im Osten
zwischen 15 und 20 Prozent im Westen
vielleicht dann 10% und wir werden auch
den stillenschwund noch haben also
mindestens ein Drittel der Firmen wird
dicht machen was ist das Kernproblem
Frau Herrmann ist es die Energie das
ändert die Energie ist das kein Problem
bei den Faktoren die so am wenigsten
beschätzt einschätzen können also jetzt
haben wir bei Öl aber bei Gas und so ein
bisschen was gemacht bei Strom aber
nicht genug nicht ausreichend da muss
man eigentlich alles anschalten was
Strom produziert um den merken sie
signalisieren Deutschland wird die
nächsten Jahre immer Strom haben bei uns
gibt's keine Blackouts das wäre das
erste Mal Signal das zweite Mal wir
haben spätestens ab Januar Februar
brauchen wenn diese ähm Öl importer aus
Russland nicht mehr kommen trifft den
Osten wieder doppelt hat da geht's um
Diesel und Benzinpreise jetzt ist gerade
mal die Inflation runter sagen ja das
waren eben jetzt die nachgegebenen Preis
ein bisschen wird alles eingepreist dann
ist vielleicht noch der Transport beim
Container überseebilliger geworden oder
irgendwas anderes und dann wirkt das so
als ob die Inflation runtergeht wie geht
wieder hoch und zwar in dem Moment wo
diese und Benzin wieder teurer werden
vor allen Dingen Diesel weil alles was
der Mensch einkaufen will wird meistens
dahin geschleppt wo es einkauft sie
waren selbst sein im Bundestag was
würden Sie Kanzler Scholz jetzt raten
konkrete Maßnahmen was muss jetzt
umgesetzt werden also er muss mindestens
bis zum Jahresende geklärt haben egal ob
die Grünen da wie Rumpelstilzchen ums
Feuer springen oder nicht dass wir
Stromproduktion brauchen über mehrere
Jahre hinweg die verlässlich und günstig
ist sie muss bezahlbar sein da sind wir
bei Atom es gibt keinen Weg dran vorbei
dann müssen die Grünen eben in Sachen
Apfel beißen und wenn sie das nicht
machen wollen dann musste er Scholz
überlegen ob er dann eben mit der CDU
das zusammen macht die müssen allerdings
auch wieder eine Kehrtwende von der
Kehrtwende machen also die Wände
es geht kein Weg dran vorbei die
Realität ist das ist kein Industrieland
gibt das gut funktioniert
äh in dem es kein bezahlbaren und stetig
anliegenden Strom gibt das ist
pillepalle die Regierung möchte ja alles
auf Strom umbauen in Verkehr und was
nicht alles ja da brauchen wir erst
recht noch mehr Strom und eh die anderen
Investitionen alle greifen sind wir im
Jahr 2027 wir müssen jetzt signalisieren
den heimischen in Unternehmern und den
ausländischen Investoren in Deutschland
probt da läuft weiter die deutschen
Großkonzerne fragraschke die sitzen dann
quasi jetzt schon auf gepackten Koffern
was passiert spielen wir das Szenario
mal weiter wenn ihr alle gehen ehrlich
gesagt da würde ich immer ein bisschen
vorsichtig sein also ich stimme der
Analyse zu das ist eine sehr schwierige
Lage ist ich denke das ist auch gerade
also klein und mittelständische Betriebe
also ich denke da eher erstmal an den
Bäcker der ist einfach nicht mehr
schafft wegen der Energiekosten die sind
schon mittendrin das ist aber auch ein
riesen Problem übrigens auch für
Soziales ich glaube was man was man
vielleicht aus dieser ganzen Sache
lernen kann die hat ja zwei Aspekte es
ist immer glaube ich sehr schlecht wenn
Ideologie zu sehr vor die Klammer
gezogen wird in den 90er Jahren wurde
uns ja von allen top Ökonomen erzählt
also die Globalisierung ist eine ganz
tolle Sache das wurde der kampfargument
gegen die gegen die Gewerkschaften und
die Arbeitnehmer verwendet die Löhne
sein hier zu hoch und und und
arbeitnehmerrecht überhaupt ganz was
schlechtes und man würde dann also quasi
zur Strafe lieber im Ausland produzieren
und Leute also Konzerne wie VW gingen
dann erst nach Tschechien und so und
inzwischen hängen sie in China in einer
ganz komplizierten Situationen das
politische System dann doch nicht so
erfreulich ist
optimistischer also insofern ja
damals hat man uns vorausgesagt also bei
diesen Löwen wird die gesamte deutsche
Wirtschaft Deutschland verlassen und das
hat sie nicht getan weil das natürlich
doch viele nahbeziehungen und viele
Vorteile sozusagen damals zumindest noch
gegeben hat man muss gucken wie das
jetzt ist mit dem Bildungssystem und so
das sind auch Faktoren
können die Leute lesen und schreiben und
können Sie ihm geben falls das lernen
was sie in der Ausbildung oder in dem
Fachstudium lernen müssen also da war
Ideologie nicht so gut denn jetzt hätten
wir die Sachen lieber gerne etwas näher
bei uns weil wir sehen was für Stress
Globalisierung reinbringt und was für
schwierige politische Fragen sei es
Russland sei es China ist eben die
Energie Frage also jetzt Rahmen der
Energiewende und überhaupt der
ökologischen Transformation der
Gesellschaft das ist ja der neueste Hit
also alles vor die Klammer zu ziehen und
zu sagen dem ordnen wir alles unter
wirtschaftliche Fragen was ich nicht
also Fragen der Selbstbestimmung der
Bürger und so da sind wir ja auf dem
besten Weg und da würde ich auch wieder
sein vorsicht also natürlich also es gab
in meiner Generation hat man sehr
gelernt dass Atomkraft sehr sehr
gefährlich ist und das Restrisiko und
man soll das alles also nach Kräften
vermeiden aber letzten Endes haben wir
in Deutschland auf einem hohen
technischen Niveau Atomkraftwerke gehabt
wir haben auch keine schlimmen
Katastrophen stehen jetzt trotzdem nicht
gut also da müsste die FDP nicht richtig
Druck machen
bei verschiedenen Themen die FDP das
finde ich eigentlich immer ganz tapfer
das ist war in der Opposition also als
praktisch einzige Oppositionsparteien
nicht ein nicht mehr in der Regierung
ist es irgendwie
also es wird angedroht sag ich mal jetzt
außer Sicht eines Unternehmen muss
Erbschaftssteuer das Unternehmen
nachfolgenden Problemen sein wir haben
eure steuernden Aussicht die werden es
durch Inflation sowieso schon über die
Mehrwertsteuer und andere eingenommen
aber auch höhere Steuern werden in
Aussicht gestellt 2024 kommen noch mal
neue Bewertungen rein also eigentlich
weiße Unternehmer die nächsten Jahre
werden alle brutal und jetzt komme ich
mal zu einem guten Mittelständler mit
einer guten Marke wenn die Marke
weltweiten Markt hat und die Leute
wissen das ist eine gute Marke dann muss
der nicht in Deutschland produzieren er
macht das gerne weil er eben seine
Heimat liebt und weil er da ansässig ist
aber er muss es nicht und wenn einfach
zu viele Daumenschrauben gleichzeitig
angezogen werden dann platzt auch den
patriotischsten Unternehmer irgendwann
mal ertragen
kann
laufen wir laufen im Ziel Konflikte rein
hinein die die sich weder die
Öffentlichkeit also in Form der Medien
noch die Politiker eingestehen wir
können nicht als größte Exportland also
als Land mit dem höchsten Exportanteil
in Europa nur mit Ländern handelt die
unsere europäischen Werte teilen nur mit
den Wirtschaft treiben wir können
natürlich nur mit den Wirtschaft treiben
ja dann verschwindet ein großer großer
Teil unserer Industrie und nicht nur
unsere Industrie vor allem auch im
Mittelstand sprechen sie da konkret ein
Kinder beispielsweise China auch in
Afrika viele Länder ich meine alleine wo
beziehen wir wo beziehen wir das Lithium
und und andere Rohstoffe für unsere
Elektroauto Batterien
und dann Albanien
jede Menge 2 Zielkonflikt wir können
nicht nur saubere Energie also nur aus
richtig sauber im Grünen Verständnis ja
nur aus Wind und Sonne Strom gewinnen
und gleichzeitig eine hoch energetische
Volkswirtschaft betreiben zweiter
Zielkonflikt im Ergebnis stehen wir
heute da mit dem einen der höchsten
Anteile der Kohle Verstromung in ganz
Europa
Teil der politischen Landschaft der
absolut ideologisch vom Atom weg will
weil nur indem wir als ob wir eine heile
Welt schaffen indem wir Deutsche das
Atom vergessen wir sind in eine
Sackgasse also überhaupt wir sind auf
einem Weg weg von der weg von der
Realität und weg vom Realismus
machen Sanktionen setzen und sie
währenddessen die Ukraine kaputt Bomben
lassen das ist Realität hat oder Moment
ich fordere ja nicht jetzt dass man sich
in dem Ziel Konflikt so oder so
entscheiden muss man kann ja auch auf
das alles verzichten wir können ja die
Sanktionen aufrecht dann wir brauchen
nicht nach China Autos zu verkaufen nur
fragen Sie dann die vw-arbeiter ob die
das Verkaufen und fragen Sie die in
Sachsen die Mittelständler die vor dem
Krieg wirklich teilweise 30 40 50% ihre
Umsätze mit Russland gemacht haben
fragen Sie die ja dann entscheidet man
sich ich ich sag nur mal aus den
Zielkonflikt erstmal bitte beim Namen
nennen Frankreich Italien beispielsweise
die kaufen LG Flüssigkeit ist auch
Russland
Moment machen wir es nicht wegen des
Ukraine kriegst und das finde ich auch
vollkommen richtig und klar also man
wird nicht alle Probleme der Welt und
nicht alle moralischen Fragen der Welt
lösen können über die den deutschen
Außenhandel aber man muss ja irgendwo
mal anfangen und die Ukraine als
europäisches Problem und und als
europäische Katastrophe ist uns nun mal
sehr nach und dann muss man eben
irgendetwas tun ja auch gesagt man muss
mal irgendetwas entscheiden
Punkt auf den wir auf den wir an der
Stelle setzen was ich nicht ganz
verstehe ist also man hört so wahnsinnig
unterschiedliche Dinge übers Fracking
und Fracking ist zum Beispiel auch
fürchterlich geächtet ich glaube da
hätten wir durchaus vorkommen die wir
erschließen könnten und das ist eben
auch auf der Todesliste der Grünen als
gar nicht diskutabel und ich glaube
diese ganze Frage so der
technologieoffenheit also wie guter
Punkt können wir also was gibt's denn
alles für Möglichkeiten nicht also auch
bei den E-Autos jetzt die sind ja in der
Öko also in der herstellungsbilanz auch
gar nicht so Batterien und die Batterien
sind ein riesiges Problem sowohl in der
Herstellung als auch in der Entsorgung
aber jetzt haben wir irgendwie
draufgesetzt jetzt muss es unbedingt und
nur das sein und das ist sehr deutsch
finde ich also dieses ganze oder gar
nicht frisst oder stirbt bleiben wir mal
beim LG Gas aus Russland
ja ich würde es holen ich würde sowieso
nach Europa reingeholt jetzt würden auch
jetzt wirklich holen es wird sowieso
nach Europa reingeholt es wird über
Portugal über Spanien über Frankreich
über Italien vor allen Dingen andere
auch also wird reingeholt die deutschen
machen jetzt einen auf besonders wir
machen auf gar keinen diesem Fall aber
sind eigentlich nicht im Mainstream der
Europäer wenn sich mal angucken wer
alles aus Russland Erdgas bezieht die
Geschichte wird dann jetzt zum ersten
entschieden also ich glaube dass die
Sanktionen nicht bei weitem den Erfolg
gehabt haben den sie haben sollten Sie
haben zumindest eine zweischneidige
Wirkung also es gibt einen
rückwirker-effekt auf uns und wir müssen
entscheiden ob wir den aushalten können
oder nicht es gibt auch Dinge wo man
sagt oh ja ich bin tapfer dagegen und
dann merkst du es geht nicht das hätte
dann passieren sollen wie was hätte
passieren soll ich sagen was hätte
passieren müssen damit sie sagen die
Sanktion waren richtig es war gut dass
wir da ein Cut gemacht haben naja es
hätte passieren nicht passieren dürfen
dass wir uns selber so ins Knie schießen
sag mal so rum also ich hätte das
geklappt ne das hätte zum Beispiel
klappt indem man nicht gleich am Anfang
rum triumphiert und sagt wir werden hier
gar nichts mehr von Russland beziehen
und dann groß einen aufmacht die
Sanktionen kamen Wesentlichen aus den
USA und die dritten haben das immer sehr
stark unterstützt die Deutschen haben
damit gemacht das war meine Beobachtung
der Diskussion ist ich finde dass die
Deutschen und die Europäer zu wenig auf
ihre eigenen Interessen geguckt haben
und ich glaube auch dass es ein
überzogen gewesen ist zu denken dass der
Russe dann irgendwann wieder in Berlin
steht aber sind ist die Ukraine nicht
europäische Interessen auf die wir eben
auch zu gucken haben das finde ich schon
also ich glaube ja nicht das Putins
Aggressionen sozusagen aufhören würde
wenn jetzt also es gibt ja auch viele
die sagen also einseitig also keine soll
einseitig verhandeln also egal wie Erde
ihr Land zusammen bombt sie sollen jetzt
mal wieder Verhandlungen anbieten das
sehe ich eben nicht so sondern also der
Krieg in der Ukraine wäre sofort zu Ende
wenn die Russen aufhören anzugreifen
wenn die Ukraine aufhören sich zu
verteidigen ist die kleine Weg so also
insofern man sieht da ein eine
unglaubliches Unrecht und und ein
völkerrechtswidrigen Angriffskrieg und
ich finde man kann das schwer mit
ansehen und wenn man junge Menschen
kennt aus der Ukraine die ja auch in
Europa sich frei bewegt haben zum
Beispiel als Erasmus Studenten und so
und die eigentlich so stark orientiert
waren auf aus Mitgliedschaft in der EU
gut die NATO Mitgliedschaft wünschen
sich eigentlich alle aus europäischen
Staaten weil sie nämlich Russland als
Nachbarn kennen und insofern so froh
waren als sie aus der Sowjetunion selbst
entscheiden durften zu welchem ist sie
gehören wollen dass also da kann man
eigentlich nur unterstützen und insofern
würde ich an dem Punkt sagen das ist das
ist sehr langes gelebt glauben Sie dass
man mit diesem Putin irgendwie
verhandeln kann glauben Sie im Moment im
Moment sicher nicht ich würde aber davor
waren ich komme auf das Thema zurück
worüber wir reden D und die
Industrialisierung weltweite Energie und
Wirtschaftskrise ich glaube wir sollten
Russlands Rolle den Rolle des russischen
Kriegs in der Ukraine von dem
Hintergrund dieser ganzen Phänomene
nicht überbewerben das war sicher der
Einstieg der Anlass ja aber die
Verteuerung unserer Energie Ressourcen
hat lange vor diesem Krieg eingesetzt
die Abhängigkeit mit Nord Stream 2 die
Abhängigkeit von russischen Gas wäre er
erst mit Nord Stream 2 mit 110
Milliarden Kubikmetern im Jahr sehr groß
geworden mit den 55 Milliarden das ging
ja noch die Abhängigkeit war natürlich
insofern leicht fertig als dass wir
gleichzeitig über Jahre hinweg auf einen
System und Werte Wettbewerb mit den
Russen auch wieder auf den
geostrategische Konkurrenz gesetzt haben
also da haben wir wissen schon auf ein
gefährliches Fahrwasser begeben insofern
bin ich fast glücklich dass wir jetzt in
der Situation sind wo auch die
marktwirtschaftlichen Kräfte dafür
sorgen müssen dass wir auch unsere
Energie Ressourcen neu finden vor allem
unser Problem ist zum Beispiel wenn wir
über den Strom reden das hat nichts mit
Russland zu den die Atom Diskussion ja
da die Energiewende hat nichts mit
Russland zu tun von 2011 also wir
sollten hier schon die Rolle des Ukraine
Kriegs
wahrnehmen und angemessen auch
betrachten aber eben nicht äh putin ist
nicht an aller Misere Schuld nicht die
Ausrede für eine missglückte
Energiewende das ist genau der Punkt
was miteinander zu tun ne die
Atomkraftwerke und Putin denn jetzt kann
man die beiden Energiethemen ja nicht
mehr voneinander trennen aber das wäre
ja vorher war das ja auch nur für
Fiktion das war immer Frau Merkel hat
unter der Hand ohne es offen zu sagen
der zu der energiewendet weil sie davon
ausgegangen ist wir können das relativ
CO2 nicht nicht vor weniger belastete
relativ bodenbelastete CO2 unbelastete
Gas aus Russland einsetzen als
Brückentechnologie bis dann irgendwann
in der zweiten Jahrhundert Hälfte oder
so Sonne und Gas
zusammenfassen die Sanktionen könnte man
sich leisten wenn man begreift dass man
dann nicht mehr mit dem Gas die
Schwankungsreserve für Wind und Sonne
machen und dass man die Atomkraftwerke
braucht dann könnte man sich dann könnte
man ja die muss man sich leisten können
und dann könnten wir uns diese Moral
leisten aber wenn die Atomkraftwerke
eben zugemacht werden und nicht diese
Ausgleich sozusagen bei den
schwankungsenergien von Sonne und Wind
gemacht werden und wir das Gas dafür
nicht haben dann haben wir ein
gravierendes Problem das heißt man muss
schon für die anderen mitdenken und für
80 Millionen ein bisschen Empathie haben
bevor man sich in die brustwirft oder
wie dem Kurve wir fragen uns schon alle
in was für ein Winter wieder Steuer